الرئيس بازوم بصحه جيده وشروط احتجازه
بدات تستد قسوه وقد قطعت عنه الاتصالات
ولكن صحته جيده وهو عازم على القتال
اخبار العالم بان غرفه اخبار الجزيره اهلا
بكم بايدن والاتحاد الاوروبيه دعواني
للافراج الفوري عن رئيس النيجر وعائلته
ومع قرب انتهاء المهله الممنوحه من الكواس
لقاده الانقلاب للتراجع مظاهرات
قاده الجيش وقائد الانقلاب يرفض عوده
الرئيس المحتجز ويقول انه لن يذعن
للعقوبات
روسيا تعلن احباط هجوم بالمسيرات فوق
مقاطعه كالوجا واوكرانيا تقول ان هجمات
المسيرات على موسكو ينفذها مناسبتهم الثور
الروس وتؤكد على ما وجود قيود على استخدام
اسلحتها المصنعه محليا في الداخل الروسي
وتكشف عن انتشار قطع بحريه روسيه مزوده
بصواريخ كاليبر في البحر الاسود
مصدر مسؤول في وزاره الطاقه السعوديه يعلن
ان المملكه ستقوم بتمديد الخفض الطوعي
البالغ مليون برميل يوميا من انتاجها
النفطي شهرا اخر ليشمل سبتمبر ايلول ويقول
ان هذا الخفض الاضافيه لتعزيز الجهود
الاحترازيه التي تبذلها دول اوبك بلس بهدف
دعم استقرار اسواق البترول وتوازنها
[موسيقى]
المنتخب المغربي يحقق تاهلا تاريخيا الى
دور 16 من منافسات كاس العالم للسيدات
التي يشارك فيها للمره الاولى بعد فوزه
على كولومبيا بهدف دون مقابل الانتصار هو
الثاني للمنتخب المغربي في المجموعه
الثامنه وسيلعب بذلك مع فرنسا متصدره
المجموعه السادسه الى اللقاء